and three pictures I want to show you
okay I wonder if you ever play this game
with you I'm gonna show you these
[ __ ] now what you think I what they
are and then I want you to figure out
what's the thread hey Cristobal don't
shut it out whether you can see one do
this I want you to think about Wendy's
and what we'll have in common with the
next two things I'm going to show you
are you ready so it's the first one it's
a bit dark
I mean you have fun so you see it they
don't look dead to me okay just have a
look at it just think about it I know
what the answer is you don't need to
tell me what you think about we'll come
back to discuss this in a second I just
want you to look at it last one okay
it's alright I want this conversation
let me just rewind
here's them this is phenomena what is
this phenomena tell me it tells you how
fast you're going in km/h okay good
it's an ECG it's called an
echocardiogram it works out among other
things it works out what your heart is
doing and particularly how quickly it's
doing it what do you think that 100
minutes it's how many times your heart
is beating every single minute and then
lastly what's that but what do these
numbers mean
it's costs right you might even be able
to see that just there it's cents per
lead up okay you with me all right the
Handy I'd like you to make is rates so
this is underneath where you're and
underneath this hitting by the other day
is a 21st if you haven't written it
already I want you to remember our
definition which is very close but
related to ratios to memory she's moved
in last week ratios are just think about
it think about it I might say
something's one to two or three to five
right ratios are a comparison between
what yeah that's right so ratios are a
comparison yes please
yes I know which we would have no you
can paid attention and heard that I'll
be reminding you or something you did
last week ratios are comparison between
two similar quantities but it could be
like centimeters and meters for instance
or cents in dollars
same kinds of things there might be
different units but they're measuring
the same thing rates are just a little
bit different rates are a comparison
between two different quantities so
think about those three things you just
looked at right get rid of the three
things the first one was a speedometer
it's comparing two quantities that are
different to each other right for
example kilometers and Howard's right so
look there's a distance a length unit
and ah what's this measure this is
turning speed is distance over time okay
that was an example what was the second
example the echocardiogram what two
things was it comparing heartbeats which
is yeah beats and again it's another
time one we measure it time along so
beats per minute actually sees example
two and then what was the last one very
good and we measured the how much the
cost in I think we're measuring in cents
cents per liter okay so you can see each
time I'm comparing two quantities you're
not just like ratios but this alone
comparing things that are different to
each other like money and capacity or
beats in minutes or commenting hours
okay so this is a really simple idea you
may sometimes need to convert things for
example Frank mentioned what if it were
dollars right how would you turn
something from say
perlier in $2 per minute for instance I
just paid about 130 one point nine cents
per lead on just a couple of days ago
for my petrol so what would I do this
number to convert into yeah divided by a
hundred do we all agree I think so so
now we're turn into a dollar three one
nine per lead up do you agree I suppose
we could down that a dollar thirty two
what if I didn't want to know the cost
per liter what if I wanted to know the
cost per mil what if I wanted to go from
cents per liter cents per liter to cents
per meal what will I do this yeah okay
let's just see what happens if I times
by hundreds a multiply by hundred this
looks like it's going to become a
hundred and thirty one dollars and
ninety cents per meal
that's an expensive picture Oh what have
we done what's going on change both
numbers by a hundred to avoid that stay
the same kind of units let me ask you
this is it cheaper than is it cheaper to
buy a mill or a leader really the
exactly thing is it cheaper to buy five
mils of petrol or five liters of petrol
is it cheaper I think I should get 5
mils that's a lot less so I pay a lot
less I didn't ask you first practical
ask it was cheaper because I that would
tell me what I should do with this
number how many the Middle's are there
in a later think mills it's a thousand
right so I'm pretty sure I should divide
yeah
does that sound more reasonable that's a
small number because mills are small